hey youtubers it's Charlie this is gonna
be my non-spoilery x-men apocalypse
video so here we go there won't be
spoilers in this there were a couple
really big things that they had to do in
this movie you have to remember it's the
third first class movie it's kind of
like the reboot franchise they retune
some of their continuity with Days of
Future past but this is still the third
movie so they wanted to pull some of the
a-list x-men off the bench which meant
recasting younger versions of a couple
characters we've seen before and try to
include some of the big fan favorite
things so there are a couple moments in
the film that are definitely for the
fans that they didn't really need to
include in there so I'll talk more about
those in my spoiler video but I think we
can all agree that the best part of the
film was Quicksilver now under normal
circumstances after a performance like
that like you just walk away going oh my
god that was the greatest thing ever
please give me more of that they would
do like a Quicksilver spin-off movie but
I don't know if Fox has any attention to
do that because as good as Evan Peters
is he's really like the punch-up guy in
this movie like it's a really a serious
movie and I think that's one of the
problems of the film in that Deadpool
was so successful and it took the piss
out of all superhero films so that every
serious superhero film that came after
felt like it was taking itself too
seriously that's why you may have felt a
little weird during Batman V Superman it
just it took itself way too seriously
this film takes itself incredibly
seriously but they do have those
Quicksilver moments of levity there is a
lot of humor in the film but it's like
the diametric opposite of Deadpool in
the x-men film universe because it is a
very serious film so I think that hurt
the film a little bit but it's not
entirely the fault of the movie itself
it has a lot to do with the character
that they chose to do Apocalypse he is
not a subtle character he is like the
end-all be-all of Evil Mutants so you
bring him out
subtlety flies out the window and all
the good character stuff lives in
subtlety and nuance so apocalypse is
simultaneously one of the coolest things
about the movie and one of its biggest
problems like if you think about some of
the best superhero action moments from
this year they were really subtle
moments like when Spiderman was trying
to explain to Tony why he wanted to be a
superhero he was starting the Uncle
Ben's story but then got all choked up
they pulled off this amazing exposition
in a really
subtle offhanded way so they didn't have
to go through the tiresome process of
retelling the entire Uncle Ben's
spider-man origin story and I feel like
they try to do a really creative job
with showing apocalypses origin story at
the beginning of this movie but I felt
like they skipped over a lot of really
important stuff almost too much
important stuff there's a lot of logic
in the film that doesn't really add up
and I think a lot of that has to do with
how they rushed the film out so they
really could have used an extra year to
get this film out one of the problems of
making big films like this is that
they're like an assembly line you have
to make them every two years so whether
you're ready or not you have to start
shooting at a certain date so you have
all these interesting characters that
they brought onto this film there are a
lot of awesome characters but whenever
apocalypse is on screen he is almost
impossible to act with most of the
scenes that I liked least in the film
were scenes where he was doing
exposition like when he was speaking
through Charles to the rest of the world
when he was going through the process of
making each of the horsemen one of the
most important things about big films
like this that usually gets lost like
one of the biggest complaints is that
the characters feel kind of weak you
have to be able to sense what the
emotional truth is of each character and
there are a lot of characters that you
totally get you definitely understand
where magneto is coming from why he
chooses the side that he chooses so the
strongest characters are naturally like
the biggest actors in the film Jennifer
Lawrence James McAvoy Michael Fassbender
they all have strong character arcs and
there's still a big part of the
franchise and that none of them has left
the franchise yet but apocalypse like
you just totally don't understand where
he's coming from other than he hates
humans and wants to rule the world false
idols the weak have taken over the world
so I felt like they didn't do a really
good job of rationalizing his emotions
but part of the problem with that is
that there haven't been that many good
stories that have parts that out even
the comics that have told his backstory
there are some pretty cool apocalypse
origin story comics even they don't do a
good job of spelling out his motivation
he's the most powerful mutant in the
world and what are the most powerful
people want more power that was one of
the big complaints against Marvel Comics
in the 90s and a lot of this borrows
from 90s comics in that characters were
doing really awesome things they were
big action set-pieces
amazing artists but the stories just
weren't that great and I think this
suffers from some of the same problems
but it's still a really fun film I just
feel like
there's a lot of different pieces that
aren't meant to fit together and they're
trying to make them fit and it just
feels a little disjointed so I feel like
the easy fix here is to get a more
appropriate villain for the characters
that you have and I feel like they set
that up in the post-credits scene I'm
not gonna explain what that is just
because it's super spoilery but they've
already teased who the big villain is of
the next movie so definitely make sure
you stay for the post-credits scene but
I'll tell a funny story here so Oscar
Isaac is the person under the apocalypse
makeup if you couldn't tell that's pod
amber and part of the problem with that
you can't tell that it's Oscar Isaac
underneath the makeup and he's an
amazing actor but there's this story
about how you know when he was acting
with all this stuff on all the
prosthetics Bryan Singer would tell him
to go half Skeletor
full Skeletor three-quarters Skeletor
so for example when apocalypse is being
really settled he's like okay dial back
the Skeletor and then you have these big
action set pieces where apocalypse is
going crazy using his powers to his full
might and Bryan Singer's like gimme full
Skeletor so anytime you see apocalypse
going crazy on screen just think of
Skeletor fondly so you should definitely
check the film out there's just so much
stuff going on that tells you what's
coming next
that it's really important I'll talk all
about that in my Easter Egg video so be
sure to subscribe to get that I'll
totally post that tomorrow they've
already got a couple other films are
working on there's a new mutants film
there's gonna be an x-force film there's
gonna be a Deadpool sequel definitely
hoping to get Deadpool and some of these
other movies soon too but I think the
most crossover that he's gonna have with
a proper x-men film will be in the
x-force movie I will say probably one of
the best things they can do for the
future x-men films the main x-men films
is to just do a creative refresh behind
the scenes usually it's not a good thing
when the same person is responsible for
producing and directing every single
film and a franchise and I think that's
one of the things that Marvel has done
really well they've got to that rarefied
air where they're totally not afraid to
find someone who just does something
really amazing and weird and give them a
hundred and fifty million dollars to do
it and I don't think that the x-men
franchise is quite ready for that but I
think they'll get there once they do
some of these other films like New
Mutants exports more Deadpool sequels I
think they'll get a little more
comfortable with doing really fun weird
stuff let me know in the comments though
what would you guys favorite thing about
the movie and please use spoiler tags if
you're going to be super specific Easter
Egg video is
tomorrow we will talk about all the
things while you guys wait for my next
video to post you can click here for my
flash season 3 video and you can click
here for all my Captain America Civil
War Easter eggs thank you so much for
watching everybody let's high five I'll
see you guys tonight